yeah welcome to this game playing Grand
Master shunned off from Denmark ok it's
not playing the the green felt his self
played the moon further and I'm not a
great experts oh ok yeah with the bogo I
mean I write this book but they don't
know it from the white side so much Kim
check
yeah black can play with g5 in these dis
lines he doesn't need to a castle player
but more conservatively but this is some
way to go so
then let's not think too long about this
I mean this is very often the right way
to to play in this type of structure and
I don't want to get it too so on Syria
time travel 90 form yep that's it's
similar but it's not the same I mean
similar to two other positions well
there's a double porn this is a bit
different double pole on the seam file
hmm yeah maybe does it threaten at four
maybe it does
hmm Kenneth f3 is not exactly an
attractive move let's try to keep it
simple yes k can play he can play 93 I
could also just castle long maybe just
cancel long and hope I've at least a
secure king yeah again very quickly
played
thought bishop d5 what thought night
isn't ip54 good move now does it have
some pic pick and roll back
yeah well I need your plate anyway so
let's just go ahead yes take on c7
hmm
yeah he can play kinky sub notes so it's
just it's just working
yeah don't have to have something else
don't have a good roof yeah I mean I was
hated when the play instantly ended some
more working and this is one of those
cases
okay maybe i can i can play 95 and try
to claim compensation maybe
Kingda 7 bishop d six nights a bishop
see to Bishop b5 is not working
unfortunately
it's even hanging was check-in and this
is really a viable idea oh no it's not
it's getting quite interesting with
Queen g7 and the mix I didn't see that
this will say hahaha oh man God hmm what
very erotic flavor me ah god I got
another darkness was silly a lot and I'm
two tons behind on the clock yeah okay
forty seconds if he doesn't manage to
win this then well thick check
a4 and b5 them actually would be it
would be quite nice but he can he can
prevent it
and this is it is of course winning for
black but I had a bit more time there
there may be it chances to to get a
sweet load of this that is it is
slightly still slightly tricky with the
King position
queen bee six is my idea at least my
king is safe
time morning
now probably not the best decision left
weighing amongst others
okay afgoo Lincoln back and also resign
but
I don't know
check
yeah and ok it's just playing this on
timer not even trying to make good moves
and this is this is why I want to play
with increment people are too stupid to
win with an extra look then they are
punished and now we can just do in our
time of course it's my problem that I
spent all this time
black fits on yes I won this crap game
yes I'm sorry but I just I just hate it
if they just don't even try to win with
a complete extra look for nothing and
you can probably make you here just ok
now let's win on time and then I mean
it's it's made in two moves even but I
one was 30 31 hundredths of a second on
the clock all right forgive me for for
this one but I liked it ok thanks for
thanks for watching